Ukraine accusing Russian forces of blowing
up a critical Dam near the front lines of
the war in a Russian-controlled area of the
Kherson region the surging Waters leading
to fears of large-scale Devastation and the
country warning of an environmental disaster
settlements Downstream are flooding
residents in the danger zone are being
urged to evacuate you can see water creeping
into Kherson City that's what's happening
right now there are more than 800 people in
the region have already been forced to leave
their homes and officials are warning people
do everything you can to save your life the
Ukrainian government accusing the Russians
of what they say is ecocide an environmental
catastrophe as well as a humanitarian disaster
they think the Russians blew this Dam in order
to flood the valley below the river valley
below which would make it harder for the
ukrainians to prosecute a cross river assault the
Russians are saying that they didn't blow the dam